papa enguerrand jeux goûter près
répondait à peine pour tout va bien
c'est pas compliqué elle viendra goûter
je ne jurerais le rôle de personne je
suis son père adoptif
je repère accompagnant la compagnie à
l'école comme n'importe quel père c'est
tout ce qu'ils demandent s'il vous plaît
je t'en parle et je sais que tout se
passera bien mais s'il y avait le
moindre souci pour m'appeler si tu fais
la maladie c'était moi d'aller le
chercher
tu m'as pas confirmé bonjour je croyais
avoir un camion logique
j'ai ça c'est pas possible jusqu'à lui
espère avoir enfin je crois qu'ils te
voit dans comme mon avion
[Musique]
d'abord j'étais présent plus vers ce
monsieur mais pas son père biologique ne
crois pas je ne suis pas ton père
biologique humaine du recul ce pas
logique
je ne suis pas tempère les fauves
biologie et ridicule kwabena est un
immigré clandestin sais pas s'il est pas
descendu du ciel c'est toi qui m'as vu
qu'ils voyageaient en bateau d'office
tabarre était de bassiner avec des
conneries
le père adoptant au lieu d'assumer des
trompettes et ses compères j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance quand 45 ans citée
je suis
ces fadas thomas anne benoit
je vais regarder ensemble ça plus de
panache
première fois qu'il en fait on reporte
sur le père parce que vous croyez
non